hey guys I'm Greg hey I'm John one of my
all-time favorite channels has released
a video on the reel Suicide Squad John
Dino but this is it's real yeah I have a
guess record that's right raka raka raka
raka raka one of the best channels of
all time and now I'm hoping that if
they're saying the real Suicide Squad
Suicide Squad are villains
I'm hoping this is some true reco rakha
[ __ ] I'm talking Gor upon Gor to the
point where it's like this isn't even
funny it's just gross that kind of makes
it pointing as a concept so silly that's
kind of funny now I feel like the joke
is in the title I feel like it's not
going to be the real Suicide Squad it's
going to be the real Suicide Squad and
they're all gonna kill this yeah you
know if you thought that joke was funny
I know I don't take a hammer I don't
think it's a joke I think already that's
what I think will happen just knowing
that oh my
so do the Christian Bale kind of oh yes
pretty cool
we're Suicide Squad ah got it
oh no no yep
are you totally guested you
a firefighter
do it guys what I'm gonna kill you back
well you better run
yo copper we're watching a video you
keep playing with the coin John you got
a right my friend dude I gotta say like
that was exactly what you said it was
gonna be it's what I expected I see that
title and rack a rack that was raka raka
Pierce tile instead of obliterating
other people with suicide you know like
they always go a little too far just a
little too far and the cutting of the
wrist things mean seem like a little too
real in the moment the other stuff was
like it is just like ridiculous suicide
stuff but you could really do but this
is like still ridiculous for someone to
take a knife out and just slice the
wrists and their veins in their arms is
just like you know it really happens a
lot I much tunes you know I feel like
that's the the space that wreck Iraq
occupies those they always give
criticism I don't really believe that I
thought the video is [ __ ] awesome
well I mean I don't necessarily like
love that kind of humor I feel like it
is a bit too real and and that's where
they go so I can't be mad at them for
doing because it's what they do
like what did I expect they actually got
some cool effects to like compliment
oh you know like there was some fire
effects regret we've seen some other
videos that they've done where their
effects are [ __ ] awesome
yeah like seeing that they're you know
like they're trying to certainly
duplicate at least a similar imagery in
some areas that most of it look pretty
good I was like these are like some good
costumes if this was like a Halloween
party and these guys showed up feel like
you guys pulled it off really well you
know they put time and resources into
this like their videos are always in a
twisted way you like well-made and they
got the cinematography down really well
too yeah yeah it's lighting was really
cool it looks good enough that it kind
of transcends like it still looks like
they could have pulled this together on
a very small budget you know cuz like
the warehouse and stuff is it super like
cinematic looking but you know when it
counts with the core and the and the
stunts and stuff because this one was
stunted his madness was like this one
had a hanging and fire you know which is
bigger than I haven't seen all their
videos were just bigger than they have a
lot of videos that are very stunt heavy
these days what I love too about this
channels they've gotten bigger and
they're their budgets have gotten bigger
but I don't feel like they keep it fun
at the end of the day
like they're just still whipping out
like some fun ideas of what to do hey
man I mean like no matter what I think
like whenever I see one of their videos
they that always they're doing them and
I got to commend them for doing that
like they always feel like Rocky record
doesn't feel like they've sold out so to
speak if that's possible I would love to
do a guest or in a rack a rack a video
I'll pay for my own plane ticket my own
hotel room if you were to let me be in a
rack a rack of video out in that country
you're from listen guys if you're new to
this channel I'm sure you might like it
if you did subscribe for maybe a second
or two to the real rejects youtube
channel John is reasons to Jerry
playlists of Jerry's videos of John as
Jerry same person really not different
and then blue house comm or the
facebook.com slash blue house social
media manager go there if you're into
horror I want to say to raka raka hey I
love you guys and I think it'd be really
cool if one day you know like I have an
idea like um I come with a violent idea
right okay so you put my mom in the
video right and then my mom was like hey
Greg we're on the same car insurance
plan can you give me money for the month
and I take out a baseball bat and I beat
my mom to death and then my sister my
sweet younger sister comes in the rich
like would you do to mom and then I'm
like I can't how my mom I can't I can't
have her tell about my mom
then I murder my sister by throwing her
out the window and maybe watch her
corpse well then my brother
jamika way does a reaction to these yes
went slice off his head that I killed
John for no reason
oh yeah yeah cuz I always die in this
kitchen yeah I ripoff John's head take
out his spine from reaching down his
neck and mom and whip it off and then I
shove it down his decapitated throat and
I kill John's family thank you
you guys watching John's family coming
for